Continental Tire Coaches Corner brought
to you by Continental Tire the official
tire of Major League Soccer soccer fans
expect the performance on the pitch and
demand peak performance on the street
that's why Continentals built a tire for
what you do whether you're heading to
the game taking kids to practice you're
going to kick it around the guys
continental has engineered a line of
tires that includes best-in-class wet
braking and superb handling Continental
Tire crowd support of the Dan Patrick
show visit Continental Tire calm for
more head coach should be UCLA Bruins
use Jim Mora back on the program how are
you coach Dan how you doing great to
hear from you did you put out any fires
yesterday oh no things were pretty
smooth around here you know we're right
in the middle of camp pretty focused our
days are pretty full so it's a pretty
much all about ball did have you know a
conversation with one particular players
what I'm sure you can talk about this
morning very very productive
conversation so we're moving forward
we're we're getting ready for the season
all right let's dive into it a little
bit here Johnny I kind of thought that
might but you wanted me on this yeah
Nanami on scope yeah you know it was
just great timing we wanted to have you
after we had clay helping on and then
all of a sudden Josh Rosen says here's
some comments about athletic and
academic high what do you take away from
his comments first of all as a coach at
a major university and playing on a high
level with football of what Josh is
trying to say well I think it's
important to know this about Josh Rosen
he's very very very well respected by
his coaches and his teammates because we
sanded C on daily basis his commitment
his work ethic his attitude his passion
for football we also know that he's an
incredibly intelligent young man that
does have opinions and oftentimes those
opinions are conveyed to others because
he is he is trying to bring attention to
some there may be less fortunate or have
less than he does Pettit eyes maybe he
feels are taken advantage of and you
know what the message to Josh is is it's
okay to have opinions
that's a twenty-year-old you're going to
have opinions now that maybe you don't
have when you're 22 23 30 50 60 that are
maybe different than when you were 13 14
15 16 17 but when you express those
opinions in a public forum and now he
expressed his opinions way back in the
spring these are not this is not a
recent interview this was way back a
long time ago but when you express his
opinions you create perceptions you
create controversy there are those who
agree with you and those that won't
agree with you and and you have to be
willing to live with the consequences
and so as a college team as a young
person to someone that's growing up and
maturing it's just important that every
opportunity we we teach them how to
manage their lives and that's the Betsi
academic experience that's the college
experience that's part of the learning
process so do I know for a fact whether
or not his opinions are valid no I know
this at UCLA according to Forbes
magazine which did an article that
combined academic and athletic
excellence will rank number two in the
country right behind Stanford so our
student athletes here are getting a
wonderful experience we spend millions
of dollars on academic support we're not
just trying to keep a nose we're trying
to graduate them our graduation success
what grade is the second highest in the
pac-12 to Stanford so you know I'm very
comfortable with the things that are
happening here at UCLA in in all of our
sports program so why does he bring in
Alabama why does he bring in the inner
light Alabama good question
I didn't I didn't ask him that you know
so I can't give you an answer why did
you feel the need to sit down and talk
to him because I'm his head coach um
someone that's known him for a long time
and my job as an educator as a coach at
UCLA is help these young men understand
how to move through life in a positive
respectful way where they're the
reflections of them that people have are
going to be positive that they're making
good decisions and
you know your father our daughters or
friends at USC young people are not
always going to say what we as adults
want them to say I think we have to
respect their opinion but we also have
to guide them and that's just part of
the process if you have restrictions
requirements on your players talking to
the media we have we have protocols with
regards to our players talking to the
media we give them media training every
year this was this interviews done
before we had it this year and I would
be talking right now but no we don't we
enter something called freedom of speech
in the United States of America and you
know part of the learning process is is
sometimes saying things that come back
to bite you a little bit and that
doesn't mean you can't have opinions and
that doesn't mean that you can't work
behind the scenes try to make things
better for everybody and I'll tell you
this Dan I wish you knew Josh as I know
him and his teammates Norman as his
coaches known because he is an
empathetic young man who cares deeply
about his teammates and he realizes that
all his teammates have not had the
opportunities that he had in life and he
wants to try to increase those
opportunities for them and everything
that josh says comes at least says now
he said some things in the past but I
think he's matured everything that he
says comes from a very very good good
place and you know Dan you're in the
media I've worked in the media and we
know that at times our words can get
twisted they can get taken out of
context I'm not saying that is what
happened here at all but we have to
understand Josh has to understand I have
to understand every time I say something
that people that interpret certain way
for instance when I was on your show a
few years ago and I was talking about
Stanford and you brought up USC and we
just played and I don't and I said I
don't give a rat's behind about the team
we just played and you know everybody
turn it into a shot at USC when in fact
I just wanted to talk about the next
game you remember that remember you got
the shirt off you remember oh that's
right
shirts out of that rifle I know you did
because you had fun with it at night and
I bore the brunt of it so you know I use
those opportunities every chance I get
with our players that demonstrate that
our words the work the things that we
say we have to own so we have to be
careful what we say that didn't get an
opinion but we have to and if we have an
opinion let's try to also offer solution
and Josh is always trying to offer
solutions but those are not covered the
way his opinions are covered
he said Jim Mora Continental Tire
Coaches Corner is college football
big-time college football full time job
for me it is for one of us as it is what
about the players yeah I'm sure it is
for you yeah I'll tell you this Dan
it's incredibly demanding but it's also
a great opportunity you know these young
men they they're getting their school
paid for unless they're a walk-on but
with that comes incredible demands on
their time on their emotions so there's
a trade-off but the great thing is is we
all decisions to make we all have
options you know if it becomes too much
for young men and then they have the
option to not do it you know so we offer
way the positives and negatives and make
and make a decision but yeah it's a
demanding command it's not for everybody
and that's one of the things that makes
it so great and so when you graduate
from UCLA with a degree that you've
earned because you've taken great
classes and then you know exposed to the
most incredible teaching minds in the
world I'll tell you what it really means
something and we graduate our
student-athletes
at the second highest rate of any school
in the pac-12 and that's behind Stanford
which is you know it's Stanford so it's
the same thing it's like you see it's
like you decide where I recruit I said
to go why'd you go to UCLA I said
because it's UCLA you know it's an
amazing place so yeah it's cop it's
demanding but at the end of the day it's
worth it's worth it for these young men
we had USC head coach clay helping on
recently and he admitted kind of
admitted that you could beat him in
armwrestling no I think he could take me
down he's a good man clay Helton is a
really good man we have a very healthy
relationship
I think there's a mutual respect we also
we also understand that we are competing
every single day tooth and nail in every
single way and you had a healthy
competition and it keeps it lively it
keeps it fun it keeps you you motivated
and activated so it's a good thing I've
seen those tight shirts that you got on
the sideline that's by design gym I mean
you're trying to put where there's a gun
show going on let's not let's not come
on let's not get any old guns on this on
this guy you know ahead and kid anybody
wooden flabby how much can you bench
right now coach I'm kind of a dumbbell
guy I work with the dumbbells and I
don't know why every day or those
anymore
yeah well you you talked about a
physical specimen now you know are you
are we doing this is this a simulcast of
you on TV yeah oh yeah oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah you want to go off the moneymaker
well you supplying that - yeah no if you
just step out from behind that desk and
show people you know
yep physique I mean I'm not right your
your man I'm not afraid okay I'm a
leader I start to love this I'm gonna
okay then I'm going to hit you with this
one tell me what Sam Darnell does better
than Josh Rosen uh they're both great
players and I both unique you know I
mean when you watch Sam Donald you see a
guy that has great escape ability he's
incredibly smart he's a great competitor
and he you can run maybe a little bit
differently than Josh when you watch
Josh you see a young man is competitive
has great arm strength and accuracy
slips and slides around in the pocket I
think they're both tremendous it's like
you know on the on the pro level maybe
trying to compare you know Tom Brady and
Peyton Manning in terms of skill set at
the college level I'm not saying either
those guys or Tom Brady or Peyton
Manning I don't want to be misconstrued
here that you probably cut my quote and
next time that Nora compares and what
was that I'm adding something like that
but uh you know on this level you know
it's probably the same type of compare
who's better Hagee they're both damn
good I'll tell you what Sam Donald does
better than Josh
Rosen what's that he gives less
controversial interviews well I think
they're both better than they're both
moving through a really incredibly
important portion of their life I know
that they they are in communication
because they're in a city like Los
Angeles where there's a you know there's
a there's a microscope on everything
that they say and we're just having fun
we're just having fun I know we are I
love it yeah well I was having fun so
we're going to chop that up and what are
we going to have more say so we can make
a t-shirt that that I can already party
with lines I'll be like this dance if I
couldn't give a rat's ass about you here
there you go you got you guys are the
best
hey coach we'll talk to you as you get
closer to the season Thank You bud
that's a gym or calve entire Coaches
Corner
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience